welcome back to our special broadcast of
inside the issues for the hour the
campaign to legalize marijuana continues
to gain momentum not just in this
country but around the world Canada just
legalized it President Trump has
signaled his willingness to end the
federal ban on marijuana many people
think that's great former Democratic
congressman Patrick Kennedy feels uneasy
about it he just heard a piece in The
Wall Street Journal warning that
legalizing marijuana could be bad for
kids well it also setback he says the
cause of social justice we spoke to him
earlier about this so I'm interested to
hear your perspective on this you're one
of the only people certainly one of the
only Democrats to say anything like this
out loud so I'd like to know what your
reasoning is well we've been through the
experience of this current opioid crisis
and everybody's pointing back to where a
Purdue Pharma marketed this very
addictive oxycontin and what was ending
up happening is that public health got
put to the sidelines while profits for
Purdue Pharma ruled public health it
took over any debate as to the real
impact of this drug overall on our
nation and then we go back generation to
the tobacco industry settlement and how
we had to learn for a long time as to
the fact that there was an addictive
substance nicotine in tobacco that was
driving commercial marketing of
cigarettes and so with all of that
knowledge why would we be surprised that
if we have a new commercial push to push
a product out called marijuana that
there wouldn't be a very deleterious
impact on our public health especially
given the fact that we know with
legalization really means
commercialization which really means a
second wait a second in Congress when we
know that the people who run the
marijuana companies are very cool
progressive people and it's they're not
in this for the money they're in it
because they want to make the world a
better place so why don't you trust them
well that's the
I think the thing that we have to ask of
ourselves are the billions of dollars
now going into investing into cannabis
and and in the many products that are
being produced I might add elixirs which
are basically the old Fanta great beige
and orange age that we grew up with
those are now being infused with
marijuana infuse THC beyond just the
brownies the marijuana industry is now
infusing gummy bears they're infusing
things like pot tarts other food edibles
is what they're known in other words
this is a a really slick very smart
marketing effort if you have money on
the line behind the marijuana industry
you're standing to gain a lot of money
in the years ahead and and yet who's
going to be the biggest one to pay the
for all of this it's going to be the
public health that pays the cost to this
it's going to be young people who are
going to think that this is an easy
alternative for me to deal with my
stress and anxiety because now I've got
all of these choices I can drink it I
can smoke it I can eat it whatever will
help me feel less anxious and and
frankly Tucker
you know amidst this mental health and
addiction crisis it's shocking that
we're not asking a condom ental question
what are we doing to help our young
people manage their stress cope with
their problems navigate their anxieties
that should be the challenge on our
country right now and yet I think we're
selling our young people down the river
by allowing a new predatory business
that feeds off of addiction that makes
money off of getting people hooked
I think that's bad for the public health
of this country I agree with you 100%
and by the way I should note for our
viewers who don't know that you
personally overcame addiction to drugs
and alcohol without the use of more
drugs and alcohol and you're a better
man as a result of that so
congratulations to you and thank you for
your perspective on that I appreciate
having me